تواصل الصين لليوم الثاني على توالي
تدريبات بحريه في مضيق تايوان تستمر حتى
يومي غدا الاثنين وذكر التلفزيون الحكوميه
لا تدريبات تشمل تطويخا كاملا للجزيره
وقدره السيطره على البحر والمجال الجوي
والاتصالات لاحداث قوه رادعه وتطويق كامل
لتايوان من دون تحديد موقع تدريبات بدقه
واوضحت القناه ان التدريبات تجري بمشاركه
مدمرات وزوارق سريعه قاذفه للصواريخ
ومقاتلات وطائرات تموين واجهزه تشويش وقال
جيش الصيني ان المناورات ضروريه لحمايه
السياده الصين ووحده اراضيها وسلامتها وهي
تحذير جدي مما وصفه بالتواطئ بين القوه
الانفصاليه التي تسعى الى استقلال تايوان
والقوه الخارجيه فضلا عن حمايتها من
الانشطه الاستفزازيه
وفي قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان قوه
الدفاع الجوي تحافظ على درجات عاليه من
اليقظه وفي حاله تاهب القصوى كما اضافت
انها تراقب عن كثب ديناميكيه القوه
الصاروخيه للجيش الصيني من خلال نظام
المراقبه والاستطاع المشترك وهي رصدت تسعه
سفن حربيه و58 طائره صينيه حول الجزيره
وقد ناشدت وزاره الدفاع في تايوان شعب
البلاد اعدم التاثر بما وصفته
الحرب الخياليه للتاثير على نفسيه